>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Karen Jaffe: If you go to Plumber
Elementary School raise your hand.
If you're in the second
grade raise your hand.
Keep it up, okay.
Welcome. I'm Karen Jaffe from the
Young Reader Center and you are
in the Library of Congress.
Anyone been to the
Library of Congress before?
A few of you have.
Have you been to the
Young Reader's Center?
>> Student: No.
>> Karen Jaffe: No.
Well I'm glad you're here.
We are here six days a week, Monday
through Saturday nine to four thirty
and we hope you'll come back.
If you can't come with
your classmates come
with your family on a Saturday.
We hope to see you.
Today is a very special
day because you are going
to meet two Capitol
Hill police officers,
Officer Renee White;
raise your hand Renee.
>> Renee White: Hello.
Good morning.
>> Karen Jaffe: And Tiffany White.
>> Tiffany White: Hello.
>> Karen Jaffe: And her K-9, which
is the name of a police dog, Hunter.
And in a little while first
you're going to hear a story
about Officer Buckle and
Gloria who's a police officer
that Officer White
will read from for you.
And then you'll have a chance
after they talk a little bit
about what they do
as police officers,
how they got to be a police
officer you'll have a chance
to ask questions.
I'd also like to thank Barb
[inaudible] our reader center
partners with everybody
[inaudible] to bring you here today
and to provide books
for you when you leave.
So we're very pleased
to have them with us.
So I'm going to ask Officer White to
begin to read the story and then she
and Tech White will talk a
little bit about what they do,
how they got there and give
you some ideas of what it's
like being a Capitol
Hill police officer.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Renee White: Good morning.
>> Students: Good morning.
This morning we will be talking,
we will be reading a book
about Officer Buckle and Gloria, but
for the sake of the book we're going
to talk about-- we're going to re--
rename it, we're going to rename it
Tech White and Officer Hunter, okay.
See this picture.
What it looks like that's
maybe going on right here?
Tell me. A lot of stuff going on.
I mean he just-- what's going on?
>> Student: He fell off a chair.
>> Renee White: He fell off a chair.
Okay let's see what's-- let's
find out what's going on.
Oh you wanted to say
something, go ahead.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: Oh okay okay.
I'm going to change the names.
It says Tech White shared her
safety tips with the students
at [inaudible] School
nobody ever listened.
Look at the kids.
They never even paid attention.
Sometimes they snored.
Does this look safe,
this picture right here?
Look what's going on.
What's going on in the picture?
Go ahead.
>> Student: All the
kids are playing.
>> Renee White: All the kids
are playing and what else?
It doesn't look safe at all.
Go ahead.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: Right.
But what's going on up
here and this kid here;
what's going on in the picture?
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: Right,
and what's-- ?
>> Student: They're
playing [inaudible].
>> Renee White: Right.
And what's she doing;
what's the teacher doing?
>> Student: The teacher is
standing on the chair [inaudible].
>> Renee White: Yeah.
Does that look safe?
What about this kid right
here, what's going on with him?
>> Student: He is jumping
around on the floor.
>> Renee White: Jumping
You don't know.
Okay let's go to the next picture.
Then one day Napville's police
department bought a police dog
named Hunter.
When it was time for
Officer, which is Tech White,
to give the safety speech at
the school Hunter went along.
See look at Hunter, he's-- you see
how he's planned with Tech White.
See how Tech White is
talking to the audience?
And they're paying attention right.
You see Hunter.
What does it look like he's doing?
Is Hunter paying attention?
What is he doing?
What's-- ?
>> Student: He's trying to
say something to the people.
>> Renee White: He's trying
to say something for the kids.
What else?
Yellow shirt.
>> Student: He's looking
at the door.
>> Renee White: He's
looking at the door.
Okay let's find out what's
going on with Hunter.
Okay right here Tech White
is giving the safety rules
and the kids are paying
attention right.
Okay. And Hunter right
here is doing what?
Is he paying attention?
>> Students: No.
>> Renee White: Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Tech White said never leave a thumb
tack where you might sit on it.
What is Hunter doing
in the background?
Jumping.
>> Student: Jumping [inaudible].
>> Renee White: The audience roared.
Tech White-- Tech White grinned.
She said the rest of the tips
with plenty of expression.
The children clapped
their hands and cheered.
Some of them laughed
until they cried.
Tech White was surprised,
she'd never noticed how
funny safety tips could be.
After the safety speech there
wasn't a single accident.
But what's going on during the
safety speech, can you tell me?
Right here.
>> Student: The like dog is
[inaudible] all around [inaudible].
>> Renee White: Exactly.
See look at this.
On the very next day an
enormous envelope arrived
at the police station; it was
stuffed with thank you letters
from the students at Neville School.
A lot of thank you notes.
One of the letters said Dear
Tech White and Officer Hunter,
thanks for coming to our school.
You are nice.
Your friend George.
Okay.
Another letter it said you
and Hunter make a good
team, your friend Claudia.
P.S. I always wear my crash
helmet, safety tip number seven.
What's going on here?
Tech White is busy.
What's going on in this picture?
>> Student: A lot of people
are talking on the phone.
>> Renee White: Right.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: She's getting a--
she's getting a lot of phone calls,
a lot of phone calls from some--
from some administrators
at the school how good she
did, at least we thought.
Let's find out what's going on.
Sorry paper paper paper.
Tech White told her
safety tips to 313 schools.
Everywhere her and Hunter went
children sat up and listened.
So you see the audience,
they're paying attention.
You got a question?
Okay.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: Exactly.
Exactly. Look at this right here.
What's going-- what-- what
Hunter's doing right here
in this picture right here,
this big picture at the top?
What is he doing?
He's saying a speech.
But we've got kids in like they're
sitting back and they're in line.
What are they in line for?
But who's giving autographs?
The dog is giving-- What are
you doing with autograph pad?
What's going on?
He's giving autographs?
Go ahead white shirt.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: Right.
But at the bottom-- see
look at Hunter right here.
At the bottom [laughter]
the dog he gets a treat.
What kind of treat does he get?
>> Student: A dog treat.
>> Renee White: A dog treat.
>> Tiffany White: A dog treat.
>> Renee White: No, he gets
something that I really like.
>> Student: Ice cream.
>> Renee White: Exactly, he gets
ice cream for being a good doggy.
Then one day a television news
team videoed Officer Tech White
in a state college auditorium.
Video. That's a lot of
people, a lot of students.
What's going on in the background?
Tell me what-- what is
Hunter doing back here?
What's going on?
>> Student: Hunter is jumping
up like a crazy dog [laughter].
>> Renee White: Is
anything going on right now?
>> Tiffany White: Sit.
>> Renee White: Go ahead.
Any other?
Go ahead.
>> Student: To me it
looked like Hunter he's shy
to do a show [inaudible].
>> Renee White: Exactly.
So we got to find on what's going
on with Hunter because Hunter wants
to steal the show right [laughs].
What is going on in
this picture right here?
They get the video, they
looking at pictures,
what is Tech White looking at?
>> Student: She's looking at the
video eating popcorn with the dog.
>> Renee White: Right.
Look at the entire picture
what's really going on there.
Yeah go ahead yellow shirt.
>> Student: What's really
happening [inaudible]
that the police officer is
watching the show on the TV.
>> Renee White: Mm-hmm.
And was he like upset with Hunter
or was he approved of his behavior?
>> Student: Approved.
>> Renee White: He was okay with it?
>> Student: Upset.
>> Renee White: Upset.
Why was he so upset?
Look at this picture right
here, why was he so upset?
>> Student: Because Hunter
was being-- playing around.
>> Renee White: Exactly, Hunter
was playing around [laughs].
Yes. What else sweetie?
>> Student: He looks upset because
the kids wasn't paying attention
to him, they were really
paying attention to Hunter
because Hunter was doing
crazy wow [laughter].
>> Renee White: True true.
Crazy wow.
So let's see what else happens.
The next day the principal
of Napville School
telephoned the police station.
Good morning Tech-- Tech White.
It's time for our safety speech.
Tech White frowned.
I'm not going to give
any more speeches,
nobody looks at me anymore.
Oh said Mrs. Topple.
Well how about Hunter,
can Hunter come?
Look at Hunter.
He went. Let's find
out what happened.
Someone else came from
the police station,
gave Hunter a ride to the school.
He made it.
Gloria set on stage-- no Hunter
sat on stage looking lonely.
Then he fell asleep.
So did the audience.
After Hunter left Napville
School it had a big accident.
Can you imagine what happened?
Let's find out.
Look at this entire picture.
What do you think happened here?
What do you think?
Go ahead.
>> Student: All the students--
all the student are
making [inaudible] outside.
>> Renee White: Outside.
And what else?
>> Student: The kids
are going crazy.
>> Renee White: They're going crazy.
Why are they going so crazy?
>> Student: They're going
crazy because all the school
and the officer didn't do the
speech and the dog was just asleep.
>> Renee White: But what--
I mean what did the dog do
when he was on the stage.
He fell what?
He fell asleep too right.
Okay. He fell asleep
just like everyone else.
Let's see.
The next morning a pile of letters
arrived at the police station.
Every letter had a
drawing of an accident.
Officer-- Officer White,
which is Tech White, was shot.
At the bottom of the pile was
a note written on a paper star.
Tech White smiled, the note said
Hunter we missed you yesterday.
Tech White we missed you
yesterday, your friend Claudia.
P.S. I'm still wearing my
helmet, safety tip number seven.
Hunter gave Tech White
a big kiss on the nose.
Look at the kiss.
Can't you tell Hunter to give
Tech White a big kiss on the nose.
Tech White gave Gloria
a nice pat on the back.
She's patting her now.
Tech White thought of
the next best safety tip.
Can you think of another safety tip
that she may have thought
of at the time?
>> Student: Be good in class.
>> Renee White: Be good in class.
Yeah that's a good one.
What's another one?
>> Student: Don't stand
on a chair [inaudible].
>> Renee White: You're right.
You're right.
Another one?
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: Exactly.
But this-- this was a-- whoa.
This was a real big safety tip.
Number one zero one; always
stick with your buddy.
Look at that.
You want to talk about this one.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: Exactly.
So-- so when Hunter
went to the school
without Tech White what happened?
>> Student: He felt sad.
>> Renee White: He felt sad
and then he went to sleep.
Everybody went to sleep.
But when they went
together what happened?
>> Student: They made
a big mess outside.
>> Renee White: Next.
>> Student: When they
were together they both--
the audience [inaudible].
>> Renee White: Right right.
I love this book right here.
Any-- any other pointers you
can learn from safety tips?
Go ahead sweetie?
>> Student: When you ride a bike
you should have a helmet on.
>> Renee White: Yes.
Yes yes yes.
Did you have a safety tip?
Go ahead.
>> Student; Don't--
don't be embarrassed
when they bite you [laughter].
>> Renee White: Any
safety tips for Hunter?
Should he always leave-- I mean
should he get a ride and go
to school without Tech White
or any safety tips for Hunter?
>> Student: When he-- when
he [inaudible] partner.
>> Renee White: Yes,
stick with his buddy.
What's that, safety rule
number one zero one,
always stick with your buddy.
>> Student: Never let
the people [inaudible].
>> Renee White: Or
they'll bite people.
Go ahead sweetie.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: Go ahead.
>> Student: If you
mess with the dog--
if you're being mean to
a dog they'll catch you.
>> Renee White: They'll catch you.
>> Tiffany White: We hope not.
>> Renee White: Does Hunter look
like he, you know, a mean doggy?
He got a ball.
He's enjoying himself, right.
>> Tiffany White: His
tail is wagging.
>> Renee White: And then guess what,
this book is technically
talking about him.
He is a police dog and we're
going to talk about that.
He's a police dog.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Renee White: He has a badge.
We're going to talk about that.
So is everyone okay with the book?
Did you enjoy the book?
>> Students: Yes.
>> Renee White: Okay.
[ Applause ]
>> Renee White: I'm sorry?
>> Student: If your police dog
is not [inaudible] it can wander
off [inaudible].
>> Renee White: If they're not
trained they can, that's true.
You've got to train a doggy.
>> Tiffany White: Sit.
>> Student: And [inaudible]--
and don't let Hunter use knives.
>> Renee White: Don't let
Hunter use knives [laughter].
Yes sweetie?
>> Student: How did
Hunter become a police dog?
>> Renee White: Okay.
>> Tiffany White: That's
a good question.
>> Renee White: That's
a really good question.
I'll let Tech White explain that.
>> Tiffany White: Hunter
became a police dog,
he was chosen by we have
trainers and they picked him
but he became a police dog
because we both went to training.
We went to school together.
So me and Hunter learned
together what we were supposed
to do to keep you all safe.
And once we finished school we
graduated and he got a badge.
You see the badge that he has on?
>> Student: Yes.
>> Tiffany White: He got a badge
which means that he passed all
of his classes and all of his
tests and that made him certified
so now he has a job to do.
>> Renee White: Go ahead sweetie.
>> Tiffany White: Yes ma'am?
>> Student: How did
he get the badge?
>> Tiffany White: How
did he get a badge?
Well he had to go to school.
>> Student: He had to earn it.
>> Tiffany White: We had to go to--
that's right, he had to earn it,
because every day we went
to school we had tests,
like do you have tests
when you go to school?
>> Student: No.
>> Students: Yes.
>> Tiffany White: Every day we
had tests, me and Hunter together,
had tests that we had to pass
and we had to get a good grade
because if we didn't get a
good grade then I wouldn't--
Hunter would not have passed and
he would not have got his badge,
just like do you get
certificates at school?
>> Student: Yes.
>> Tiffany White: Sometimes
when you do good work.
That's what we have to do, we have
to make sure that our work was good
so that when we come
out on the street
to protect you all we know what
we're doing and we're certified
and that we did a good job.
So that's how he got his badge
and that's how he started working.
Yes?
>> Student: Does Hunter get paid?
>> Tiffany White: Does he get paid?
>> Student: Does Hunter get Paid?
>> Tiffany White: He does get
paid, I mean he gets food, that's--
that is a-- he doesn't get
money but Hunter enjoys his job
so every day he comes to work
it's like playing for him.
So for him that's his
reward and his treat, so.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Tiffany White: Does-- ?
>> Tiffany White: He does a
lot of what's in the book.
He likes to play.
You saw he likes to
go around and play
and sometimes he won't keep still
and he will steal the show a lot.
But he also listens when he's
with me so he does a lot of--
a lot of what you read in the book.
Yes?
>> Student: Does he do tricks?
>> Tiffany White: Does he do tricks?
Not a lot of tricks but he finds
things, that is his best trick.
the one thing that
he'll do is find--
he'll find anything here on
Capitol Hill that may harm you
so that we can find it and get rid
of it so that you all will be safe,
so that's the biggest trick
that he does every day.
Other than that, I mean he'll
shake your hand when you're ready
and you come around he'll
shake your pay if you want
to he'll shake your paw for you.
And he's a retriever so every now
and then if you throw something
out he'll go get it, he'll go back
and retrieve it and bring it back.
So those are some of
the tricks that he does.
Yes, question in the back?
>> Student: Will we
get to [inaudible]?
>> Tiffany White: Sure.
You'll get a chance to pet him.
I think we're going to answer
all the questions first.
Yes sir?
>> Student: That's a nice dog.
>> Tiffany White: Thank you.
He is a nice dog.
>> Renee White: He's great.
>> Tiffany White: He is a nice dog.
>> Student: He's a very calm dog.
>> Tiffany White: He's calm.
He is calm.
Very mel-- Yes?
>> Student: Does he like meat?
>> Tiffany White: Does
he like sweets or meat?
>> Student: Meat.
>> Tiffany White: Meat yes.
He likes food, anything
food he likes.
Come. Come.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Tiffany White: Yes.
Yes. He does.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Tiffany White: You
know he grew overnight.
When I got him he was not this big
and I think every year he
grows a little bit longer,
just like you all get
taller every year, you know,
so every year he gets
a little bit longer.
Do you know how old Hunter is?
>> Students: No.
>> Tiffany White: No.
Can you guess?
How old do you think he is?
>> Student: Seventy-five.
>> Student: Five months.
>> Tiffany White: Five months,
no; he's a lot older than that.
>> Student: Two months old.
>> Tiffany White: No,
he's a couple years.
This-- in the front.
>> Student: Fifteen.
>> Tiffany White: Fifteen, no.
He's not-- he's got some gray
hairs though, see the gray.
He's not 15 yet though.
>> Student: He is 20 years old.
>> Tiffany White: No, he-- I'll
tell you; he's eight years old.
>> Student: What!
>> Tiffany White: Yes.
[ Children Yelling ]
>> Tiffany White: Hunter is eight.
Yes?
[ Children Talking ]
>> Tiffany White: You can-- I think
we're going to pet him in a minute.
We'll do a line so everybody
can get a chance to pet him.
>> Karen Jaffe: Tech White
would you tell us about the ball
and how that's used for training?
>> Tiffany White: Yes ma'am.
Okay Hunter has a ball in his mouth
right now and when we find things
on the Hill, you asked me about
tricks, so when we come to work
and we find things sometimes
he'll get a special ball,
he'll get a special
treat, and he only gets
that when he finds harmful
things that will hurt people.
So whenever we go out to work
if he finds it then he'll
get a special treat.
But this ball that he has now
is his toy, he just likes it
and it keeps him calm and he likes
to chew on it, as you can see.
It's one of his favorite toys
but we use it in training.
Like you said to fetch he'll
throw it and bring it back.
So that's pretty much it.
>> Karen Jaffe: Renee.
>> Renee White: Yes.
>> Karen Jaffe: Tell
them how long you've been
at the library, how you got here?
>> Renee White: Oh wow.
I've been here for 18 years
as a police officer,
Capital Police Officer.
I came here by way of
Washington Hospital Center,
and before that I used
to work at D.C.,
D.C. jail, which is 1901 D street.
Here is such eclectic; there's
so many different people here
meeting every day all day long.
I normally work the door; I saw all
of you all when you came in earlier;
that's my favorite
door; that's processing,
when you went through the
magnetometer and some of you all had
to put your backpacks
on the X-ray machine.
On the X-ray machine we look at
your bags and see what's going
through it, make sure, you know,
you had sandwiches and cookies,
all good stuff was in there;
you all have a lot of food.
>> Tiffany White: Ooh.
>> Renee White: You're
making me hungry.
But I saw that.
And normally do what
Hunter does but I mainly--
he's in the street,
I'm in the building.
Him and Tech White is in the
street in a car, in a fancy car;
I'm mostly in a building.
Yes ma'am?
>> Student: How long has
Tech White been working here?
>> Tiffany White: Me?
Okay I have been here it'll be
10 years this year and Hunter
and I have been together
for five years.
So he's been my partner
I got him when he was two years
old and he lives with me every day.
So every day he comes home with me
and then we get up in the morning
and we get ready to
go to work together.
So we don't spend a
lot of time apart,
so we're together all day
every day and at night too.
>> Renee White: Yes.
Right there.
>> Student: Is that your dog too?
>> Renee White: My dog too?
No.
>> Tiffany White: No.
>> Renee White: That's her
dog, he's assigned to her.
Yes.
>> Student: Do you work together?
>> Tiffany White: We work together.
>> Renee White: We work together.
>> Tiffany White: But
he's assigned to me.
>> Renee White: Yes.
>> Student: Are you two sisters?
>> Tiffany White: No.
>> Renee White: No.
>> Tiffany White: No, we
have the same last name.
>> Renee White: Same last name.
>> Tiffany White: But we're
not-- we're not sisters.
>> Student: Is he like
your assistant?
>> Tiffany White: I'm like
his assistant actually.
I'm like his-- I-- he does a
lot of the work and I assist him
because Hunter has a good nose.
You see his nose?
>> Student: Yes.
>> Tiffany White: His nose is
what does a lot of his work.
So his nose is very strong.
You know how if you ever go
to Burger King you smell a
hamburger before you even drive in
or you go into the Burger King?
Well Hunter will not just smell the
hamburger, he can smell the mustard,
the mayonnaise, the pickle,
the ketchup, the cheese,
so he can break all that down.
Sit. And so that is why his nose--
>> Renee White: I know I'm dirty.
>> Tiffany White: His nose is used
to help us find explosives
and things that blow up.
So I help him get to where
he needs to go and we work
as a team together to find things.
So.
>> Renee White: You
see his little badge?
You get to see his
badge when you come up.
>> Tiffany White: Yeah,
he's moving a lot.
>> Adult: [inaudible] test
people on the hill with Hunter
or is he only looking for things?
>> Tiffany White: He's
only looking for things.
So he's only looking for explosives.
If you know what like bombs are,
things like that, those are the type
of things that me and Hunter go
and search for every day, so.
He doesn't-- he doesn't work
on people but we do have dogs
that smell people themselves.
They don't smell like sitting
objects like chairs and--
and cars and trucks; those are
the things that we look at.
We look at cars, trucks, we go
in rooms, we go in buildings.
But we have some dogs
who only sniff people.
As you're walking by they might
sniff you but you're not supposed
to pet them because they're working.
>> Renee White: They're working.
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Tiffany White: Yes.
>> Renee White: It was an-- yeah.
>> Renee White: Uh-huh, yeah.
>> Student: Where is--
what if Hunter finds a
person how can he tell you
that it's a person,
that it's a bad person?
>> Tiffany White: That's
a very good question.
What he'll do is because we
spend so much time together
and we train together he'll give
me certain signs that tell me
and only the person who owns
him can pick up on that.
So you wouldn't know because he's
not your dog but I would know.
There'll be different
behavior changes.
He may change his behavior
in one way or another.
You know like when you're angry
you may go like this, you know,
or when you're happy you smile,
so it's little things like that
that you can pick up that you
learned while you were in school
and that's how-- that's
how you're able to tell
if it's a bad person or not.
Yes sir?
[ Inaudible Response ]
>> Tiffany White: That could be.
It's very true.
>> Adult: So when he retires
[inaudible] would you keep him
or someone else adopt
him [inaudible].
>> Renee White: No that's her dog.
That's her dog.
>> Tiffany White: No, he'll--
when he retires he'll stay with me
and then I would get
assigned another dog.
So, but he-- more than
likely he goes home
with the handler that has him.
Yes ma'am.
He's already a part of the
family so I can't let him go.
[ Laughter ]
>> Tiffany White: Yes ma'am?
>> Adult: Does he go
on vacation with you?
>> Tiffany White: No.
That's the only-- that's the
only time we're not together.
We have department
issued space where we--
we leave them so they're cared for
by other members of the department.
>> Renee White: Yes ma'am.
>> Adult: How do you all
determine, like because they're--
they're different breeds of--
they're different breeds
of police dogs
so how do you all determine
what breed is
for like a specific location
or a specific building,
like they have German
shepherds and--
I mean do you know what I'm saying?
>> Tiffany White: No, I
understand what you're saying.
We do have a lot of different
breeds of dogs but up here most
of them do all of the same work.
The German shepherds do
the same thing as the labs,
as the retrievers, we're all
looking for the same thing.
The only difference is the dogs that
primarily are searching people most
of those are Labrador retrievers.
But the German shepherds
do the same thing,
he does the same thing
as the German shepherds.
>> Adult: Thank you.
>> Tiffany White: You're welcome.
>> Karen Jaffe: Okay if we
don't have any other questions--
>> Tiffany White: One
more, one more question.
>> Renee White: She got--
>> Karen Jaffe: And form a line
and let you come and pet Hunter
and then we'll do a group
picture; is that okay Shawn?
So we'll do the petting
and then our photographer
and Sasha will help
put you all in a place
so we can do a big picture, okay.
>> Renee White: Last question.
>> Karen Jaffe: Alright can we
stand up then and form a line.
Back there.
>> Adult: Last question.
>> Karen Jaffe: Okay,
one last question.
>> Adult: Why did you choose
to become a police officer?
>> Tiffany White: That's good.
You can start.
>> Renee White: Oh gosh
that's a good question.
I've been in this field for okay 18
years here, a total of over 25 years
but it's-- it's a-- it's a field
that's you get a lot of fulfillment
from it; it doesn't
seem like it but you do.
You get to learn a lot of
things about people, behaviors,
and everything, meet and
greet people and kids.
You get to go out and do community
service and stuff like that,
so it's enriching and it enhances
your personality and you're able
to go out there and speak and
teach people all walks of the world
because that's what we
see up here on the hill;
we see everyone [laughs].
And so that helped me a lot.
>> Tiffany White: Prior to becoming
a police officer I spent a lot
of time behind a desk and in a
lab; I went to school for biology
and I decided that that wasn't
exactly what I wanted to do.
So I wanted to be more
out in the public
and help people and
be more hands on.
So that's how I chose the career
field of becoming a police officer
and it's been very rewarding and
fulfilling ever since so I'm glad
that I chose it and no
more labs for me for now.
So.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.